-Welcome back!
-Aah!
-Thank you so much for traveling
all the way out here
to New York City. You had your
premiere last night in L.A
-I did.
-Was it exciting?
-My God, it was so exciting.
And it was even more excitin
when I forgot my ID
this morning at the airport.
-Yeah, and yet you still
got on an airplane?
-At 4:30 in the morning.
-Wow.
-I don't know why
they let me on.
-Is it "Parks and Rec?"
Do you think that's it?
-No. I don't --
There's like a secret --
I don't know if anyone
is supposed to know this,
but you can totally get on
a plane with no ID.
[ Laughter ]
It's not a thing.
-Yeah, I don't people
are supposed to know that. Yeah.
-Yeah, they just search
every, like, crevice.
-Oh, they were --I got you
Well, they --
I'm surprised they let you o
because you at your premiere -
I don't even understand
how it works.
You wore a knife to the premier.
-Yes, I did.
-And yet they let that person --
That person flew without I
this morning.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Now, I didn't bring the burett
to the airport, but --
-It's really cool.
-Thank you.
-And were you aware --
So Chucky came out
when you were tiny.
-Yes.
-The original Chucky.
-And were you aware of Chuck
as a horror film?
-I was. I didn't -- I wasn't
like, a big horror movie fan
But I have a lot of cousins.
And my uncles showed, like
all my of cousins Chucky
when they were, like, toddlers
-Uh-huh.
-Like 3 years old.
-Oh, yeah.
-And it traumatized them.
-Yeah.
-And I saw it, like,
not when I was 3, later on
But it's just been, like,
thing in my family for so long
-But it was very sweet.
You had your cousins all come.
-Yes, I did.
-You had a bunch of them.
-I flew out here from Philly
-That's great.
-We got real crazy.
[ Laughter ]
-They look both --
They look stylish.
They look --
-Oh, yeah.
-They also look maybe, like,
they're a little traumatized
to be walking into
a Chucky movie.
-I mean, they look, you know -
They're just partying.
What can I say?
[ Laughter ]
They had blast.
-This is not --
your Chucky is not
a possessed Chucky.
This is sort of
an AI-gone-wrong Chucky.
-Yes. This Chucky is
a re-imagined Chucky.
He's an evil smart doll
that's connected to the cloud.
So he can control
all of your devices.
And it's kind of --
It's a warning...
-Yeah.
-...to the world.
-You're being serious, because
I think we are in agreemen
in fear of robot technology.
-Yes. Robots will kill us all.
[ Laughter ]
I think we're naive in thinkin
that these devices
aren't going to turn on us
one day.
-Yeah.
-I don't like them at all.
And it's part of why
I did the movie.
-And do you have any of
these devices in your home
Do you have any smart devices?
-Yes. I have some --
Yeah, my boyfriend is very int
the smart home kind of thing
He's connected all of our
light bulbs onto the app.
-Uh-huh.
-I have to talk to the thing
to turn things on,
which I really don't like to do.
-Gotcha.
-So I -- Yeah.
I basically was just like,
"You can do that to every ligh
except for the one
that's right by my side
of the bed
so I can just turn it
on and off."
-You just want
the old-school switch.
-Yeah. I don't want to tal
to a robot.
I don't want to talk
to a machine.
-Yeah.
Certainly not right before bed
You don't want the last person
you talk to to be a robot
that you and I both believ
is trying to kill us.
-No, I don't trust Siri
or Alexa.
-No, I don't --
-They both sound evil to me.
-Yeah. And I think they
talk to one another.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah!
-I think when you go to bed,
your Siri and your Alexa
get into it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Right?
-Yes.
-You went to
the "MTV Movie Awards,"
and you wore -- So they cu
to David Spade during the show
and you were in the shot
wearing a Chucky mask.
-I don't know what you're
talking about.
-Aubrey, are you telling m
that's not you?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Be honest.
I'm giving you an opportunit
right now.
[ Chuckles ]
-I don't know who that is, Seth.
-Oh, I also -- That was --
That's not you.
-No.
-This is not you at your best.
This is you at your best.
Look at this.
When my "Cosmo"
came this week...
-No!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Stop! Don't!
-I'm in it, too. I'm in it, too.
-Stop. Don't.
-Look, there I am.
Just me on my thing.
[ Laughter ]
Me on my boat.
Just rigging my boat up.
So Mark Hamill was the voice
of Chucky?
-Yes.
-He was the original
voice of Chucky, yes?
Or no?
-When we were shooting, no
-No, like in the --
Was he not the early?
-What? No.
No, he's Luke Skywalker.
-I know that.
But was he Chucky in 1988?
-No. Brad Dourif was.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Chucky's a robot now.
-Oh, right.
So he has a different voice.
-Yeah, Mark Hamill is doing,
like, a robot --
evil robot voice.
-Gotcha.
-But Chucky, yeah, no.
-Okay.
-Chucky's not a possessed doll
anymore.
-I know, we established that
-Okay, fine.
[ Laughter ]
Whatever.
-What about Brian Tyree Henry?
-Brian Tyree Henry is the best
-He's the best, right?
-Yeah, I don't know why he did
the movie because every time
I saw him on set he'd be like,
"I don't like kids
and I don't like dolls."
[ Laughter ]
And I'm like,
"That's literally all we hav
for the next two months."
-And this was not a CGI film
You had a lot
of practical dolls around.
-Yes. There was a lot of -
-Are you scared of dolls?
Like, I mean, again,
it's not just dolls.
It's, like, this doll.
-Yeah, I --
I got used to the doll.
There were, like,
nine animatronic --
there were nine different type
of dolls on set.
And they were just --
They were super creepy.
I wasn't scared of them.
But one of the animatronic dolls
at one point,
its head started smoking.
-Yeah.
-And the AD was like,
"Get back! It's gonna blow!"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Jesus!"
And its head burst into flames
-Did it really?
-Oh, yeah.
-That would have been
a tough way to go.
"Yeah, did you hear what
happened to Aubrey?
The doll blew up."
-Yeah.
I also, like, did a stunt
where there's different kind
of dolls.
Like, some of them are,
like, soft dolls for stunts.
And some of them are, like
hard dolls for whatever --
animatronic whatever.
-Yeah.
-And I was, like,
head butting the doll
and I didn't --
I'd forgot because
I was so into my character
that the doll --
that I wasn't using
a stunt doll.
And head butted
the animatronic doll.
[ Laughter ]
Like, really, really hard.
And got, like, a golf ball-sized
thing, or whatever.
-And that's -- I mean, that'
why when the robots do take over
they're going to remember that
-Yes.
-And they're going to
come for you first.
-Yes.
-So you better wear
your knife barrette on that day.
-Yes.
-Thank you for being here.
It's always so great to see you.
-Thank you!
-That's Aubrey Plaza, everybody.